bitcoin's price is crashing and
everyone's wondering michael saylor who
owns over 129 000 bitcoin as part of the
micro strategy balance sheet are they
going to get liquidated are they going
to have to sell now this is an insane
question this is a publicly traded
business with somebody who's been
running public companies for decades now
and of course they've prepared for all
sorts of volatility but just to make it
clear michael saylor tweeted this
morning and said no they will not have
to liquidate their bitcoin at twenty one
thousand dollars here's the exact tweet
he said when microstrategy adopted a
bitcoin strategy it anticipated
volatility and structured its balance
sheet so that it could continue to
huddle through adversity he quote
tweeted his previous tweet back in may
where he said that they had a 205
million dollar term loan and they need
to maintain 410 million dollars as
collateral that means that they could
continue to hold bitcoin even if it
dropped all the way down to 3562
and then at that point they could just
post some other collateral microstrategy
and michael saylor they're not selling
and they're not going to get liquidated
at 21 000 all these people who keep
chirping on the internet they just don't
know what they're talking about but
naturally what we're watching is that
the bitcoiners the people who actually
understand what the true value of a
digital decentralized open source
currency is
they're holding for the long term and it
wouldn't surprise me if most of the
individuals who've been around for a
long time they're actually buying up
bitcoin at these levels the current
price of bitcoin is trading below the
on-chain cost basis and usually
historically that's been a great time to
buy up cheap bitcoin now if you want to
understand what public companies are
doing michael saylor has put forward the
definitive answer they're not going to
get liquidated at 21 000 they ain't
selling so go back into your troll holes
and leave everyone alone hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time